the definition of on the spectrum is
that we are all on the spectrum it's
from
zero to one and everything in between so
but i also think i i don't know [ __ ]
oh yeah you're autistic for sure oh yeah
you're more autistic than me oh yeah
hell yeah
basically if you listen to podcasts more
than four hours a day
[Music]
what's korean zombie
he's a fighter
that's a fighter
that's what i was thinking
which was like one of well he still
wanted
155
best fighter to ever come out of korea
they call him zom because he never backs
up he just continues to go gets hit and
just fun continues to go yeah that's a
dope name saw what he looked like
not what i was expecting would you
expect someone like your
oh yeah he's a smaller dude he looked
like a uh world war ii like guy like he
had like the world war ii haircut with
the last fight he went to the military
for two years and he didn't mention
south korea
uh i'm pretty sure south he wouldn't be
able to be here if he was north korea
and i don't think they don't want any of
them what about the lady who's on joe
rogan i mean you have to sneak out right
right yeah somehow smuggle yourself out
yeah you'd think they would smuggle
people they would pretend to smuggle
people out to create spots north koreans
but
yeah maybe they are no they actually do
there are north korean spies in korea
and here too i bet that woman who was on
joe rogan i mean she's full of assault
she could be a spy
there's a lot of people saying that
there's a lot of consequences
online about that with her about her
being a spy north korea about her story
not exactly
she was apparently like an actress in
north korea and had it like they say she
had it better
and they were saying we don't know how
good is better in north korea because we
don't know anything so
yeah korean zombie hit with the first
ever twister
submission in ufc and then the second
ever was frequent this past weekend
guess bryce mitchell yes which is so
dope brendan was talking about bryce and
korean zombie fighting which i think
would be
yeah it'd be pretty dope i mean
twister guys
i mean for the rest it's like a good
changing of the guard yeah yeah what
happens if twisters hit each other
can you imagine a double twist it's the
finger of god
that's a quote from twister the movie
they're like what's an f5
it's the finger of god i started
watching twister first i don't remember
why but i started re-watching it and it
is a horrible movie
it's the cgi and stuff like when they
like show like the cow flying and stuff
and the quote i said actually might also
be from the movie twisters which is
different and it starts devin
no one's seen this
who's also an mma fan yeah he was uh he
used to be on an aerial hawaii show all
the time
do i have to bleep that name
oh is this from twister or twisters i
remember like why would you want to
watch a movie about tornadoes and
tornado chasers i was like watching for
a little bit i'm like this is not
entertaining at all have you seen the
movie sharknado
of course i watch a part of it because
everyone it was like such a joke but it
was supposed to be like entertaining but
i didn't like that either was that wait
that was supposed to be a serious
without supposed to be a spoof
sharknado yeah it was supposed to be
like a campy low like purposely low
budget like old-school horse and they've
developed like a cult following yeah
yeah tara reed oh this is cats after
dark
the uh
really the thick boy after show we are
going to start trying to tie it back
more to king and the sting we've got
some plans which we'll announce later uh
we're back with the regular crew you
know us same people
we got chin
brows
all right christian
skinny george and ari you know the big
six that's what we call us
ari mantis always together were people
complaining that it wasn't king and a
sting related enough
i in my own head i'm like what the hell
are we doing here
yeah uh but uh but i i've seen it and it
does i mean it does make sense we're
leeching off the name we could at least
pretend to talk about the subject
material but uh it'd be fun to do trivia
too and go through some of that
yeah that's what nick was mentioning i
think we're gonna we're gonna do that up
we want the
the most hardcore king and the sting
fans to submit and they can't just be
like we're not gonna pick people
randomly we want you to send in
submission videos minute or less letting
us know why you're the biggest king in
the sting fan and then we're gonna do
some sort of trivia tournament over a
number of episodes that we're still
figuring out and uh winner will at least
get a year free of patreon which is
amazing i think and i i have bigger
dreams but i have to get it approved
because i'm not going to pay for it
myself
for the winner i have bigger dreams for
the winner and beyond that i guess just
fly out and stay
with me in my apartment in my bed damn
that's cute that's pretty good dudes too
right yeah guy or girl have to be cute
so you guys have lodging
covered
all right okay i got points
i got delta points
what is it what is your what if it's a
female fan
you have a girlfriend now you're having
sex four times a day she's over time
three ways that's dope that's dope thank
you i saw you're not gonna happen but i
saw your close friend story uh
[ __ ] showing off the goods over there
yeah i went to ojai yesterday with the
lady and we went hiking took a picture
of her waterfall wow posted a close
friend's door he's nice that's pretty
good thanks brother that's generous of
you
i can't follow him
[Laughter]
how far is ohio from here hour and a
half uh north or east west north
east northeast east i think yeah
i don't know
so i guess closer to stand up yeah
here in santa barbara okay cool ari you
guys know him he opened for theo stand
up comedian comedy store regular is that
right are you okay family store unpaid
regular unpaid
that's an unnecessary word to me you're
a comedy store regular
uh and that's the difference because
if you know a theo goes up
he gets a fifteen twenty dollars
to do that nice if i go up i get jack
[ __ ] i heard in the main bottle of water
is this true in the main room you get
300 now if it's sold out so the main
room the way the comedy store works if
you perform in the main room there on a
comedy store show
50 of the door goes to the comedy store
and then they divide up 50 of the door
amongst the comedians on the show so if
it's sold out main room show it equates
to about 300.
two to three hundred
i wonder how much the ticket sales
compare to
the food sales do you have any like
ratio in that because i'm like they
always talk imagine it's less
uh i think it's you they you think the
food food and drinks i would say is more
than the door yeah 100 hundred percent
because the door is 20 even on a dope
night is 25 bucks a ticket not crazy
but the food
is a rip-off in all microwaves so the
cheapest beer is fourteen dollars
fourteen dollars for a beer that costs
the store probably seventy five cents
yeah
uh
not complaining that is the comedy
business model as old as time uh but uh
that's just how it's gonna be if you go
there um i love that though i was trying
to compare it to like people always say
the ufc has low fighter pay because only
18 of revenue goes to
uh the fighters whereas like in all
the major sports like mlb nba nfl it's
closer to 50 because they have unions
which like bargain for that so i wonder
like how
that's probably about
only it's probably around 15 to what
goes to the comics
yeah 50 of the doors those are the most
successful comments yeah that's paid
regulars at the common store then you go
to us we lose money doing comedy
most of the time at eight dollars
eight dollars a gallon you do yeah i pay
15 bucks sometimes i'll go to the common
store for a spot and i have to pay 15 in
parking and then i go to an unpaid spot
you're walking distance to the copy
sometimes i'm driving yeah
i'm coming from somewhere else
do you notice like if when you do sets
at the comedy store like does your
following go up
no
really down uh
it stays the same because
i don't know like are you are you asking
if i get tagged by the comedy store or
anything like in fans like
let's say i perform in a show
with
10 other comedians
even if i stand out i'm performing for
an audience of let's say 100 people
how many of those hundred are reaching
out and be like following maybe a couple
it's not you know it's not significant
but i get probably more followers from
being on cats after dark than i would
performing in the main room that means
he gets at least like
three a few
that's dope that's still okay
i usually see a comedian i follow them
if i if i don't know him if i'm in the
place i'm like oh he was dope let me
follow him i'm probably wanted yeah
you're one of the few people or maybe
i'm very unlikable and all the other
comedians get way more followers i don't
know i don't like that yeah
yeah what would you uh consider like a
home game for you if not like the comedy
like when you perform what do you what
is your like
butter yeah the comedy store is one of i
was a door guy there for five years okay
so i worked there for minimum wage for
five years five years doorman security
guard whatever you want to call it
so that that place feels like home the
ice house in pasadena okay another one
that was the first club i performed at
yeah what's your guys's home
podcast yeah did you ever have to do
anything security wise like actually
kick people out or anything yeah but by
the time it came to us to do that the
person was always
belligerently drunk so it wasn't that
hard oh okay it was never like a tough
sober guy that's like get the [ __ ] off
this guy who could barely stand so he
could just pick him up take him out i
mean you told an incredible story on
king and the sting about a friend you
brought to this comedy store that made a
scene oh yeah i remember this one
that's incredible that you don't know
the one that you the one that you filmed
the apology for and then said your dates
at the end
oh
oh that story yeah yeah
is that uh public available your apology
i would love to watch it actually it's
on my youtube somewhere if you type in
maybe ari manis apology it's a 360 video
so it's hard to grasp the full comedy of
it
over this podcast ari mantis apology one
of six billion results
i apologize
let's see am i two ends in mantis
uh
no it's none of those
does the apology give the context in it
or should we should you
uh it's not popping up in there you
might have to go to his channel but so
basically the context is i told the
story on
king and the sting what two years ago
yeah so i think it's time to retell so
basically
i was speaking with
on social media lady of the night
a
prostitute which i did not know at the
time sex work is real work i thought it
was just a girl on instagram i was
talking to
i said hey come meet me at the comedy
store
let's see if i tell the story the same
way the second time because it's so
foggy
i tell it it's crazy that you this this
this to me is something that would stick
out as i tried to block it out
this is not a fun night remember the
name of the episode
it wasn't an episode of king in this day
oh no or at least of the video oh my
videos uh so apologies not yeah popping
up for some reason
maybe type in
oh that one official statement
there's tommy's arrest that third the
official statement yeah the blue light
comedy story
actually smart don't call it an apology
statement okay so yeah tell tell what
happened before okay so
dm'ing this girl i invite her over to
the comedy store for a drink she gets
there she's wasted she goes on to tell
me that she is a
a prostitute and that she had hooked up
with a couple guys that night for money
but she was she going with you just for
a good time yeah no i she
not a client you never discussed
pain there was none of that she just
came over to meet me that'd be a mean
bait and switch that would be mean
and then she ended up making out
with
me on the patio as well as another male
comedian
who you can't say
i think it was
i'm not going to say but not not a
famous one and then how far in between
though when you made out with her oh
like two minutes
and honestly
i don't know what it says about me
neither of us really cared yeah right
yeah it was not like what are you doing
my girlfriend
that god that's my woman
she uh were you first or second that was
first and second you guys were all way
past that
neither of you were first or second yeah
so
probably should not have gotten her any
drinks but got her glass of wine are you
a gentleman i didn't realize i don't
think i realized how
intoxicated she was so then
at the time i ran the podcast studio at
the comedy store which was in the
basement
go get it right under the original room
hustler um
so i said hey we should go to the
podcast dude i said this tour i'll go
give you a tour of the podcast studio
nice
so you have to take these kind of steep
stairs to the basement she's in high
heels we head to the basement
and she
trips
now she doesn't fall down the stairs she
catches herself but she made a loud
stud with her heels and just it was
causing attention so i was like you know
what let's go
let's go back up
so we start
heading back up and at this point she's
creating a scene i don't even remember
what she's yelling about she's yelling
to the point where
security is called and at this point
when i catch when that security is
called
i decide
my best option
is to go hide in the kitchen and pretend
like i don't know this person
so i go to the kitchen economy store i'm
hanging out there
security is now dragging her out to the
front of the commie store
she's i think tackling one of them i
think she might have tried to bite one
of them security of the copy store is a
aspiring comic so
actually
one of them his name was curtis really
nice guy ended up becoming the manager
of the comedy store she called him the
n-word like she took over for adam egret
no adam eget was the talent coordinator
he booked the lineups manager is just
kind of uh gotcha making sure everything
runs smoothly waitress is door guys
schedules yeah uh i know his name's adam
eget that's what norma mcdonald would
call in front of guests
so
cops calm it's a whole big scene they're
arresting this girl everyone's taking
videos of it and she's screaming as
she's getting arrested where's arie
sorry
where's zaria and i'm just hiding out in
the kitchen as you should yeah
and she really liked you
remembered my name
and in fact she did she messaged me the
next day she's like i just woke up and
left jail
she goes what happened last night things
like that and then of course i just
ignored her and then the follow-up text
that is you know what [ __ ] you blah blah
damn anyways
how much time be
between the turn
of the just yeah
just checking in to [ __ ] you five
minutes
two minutes
and then
just checking in so yeah i woke up the
next day getting texts of course from
comedians and staff at the comedy store
going who was that what happened last
night so i felt
i felt paranoid that i would never get
booked at the comedy store again after
that and i made this apology video
statement statement that's right
my name is ari mannis and i want to
thank you all for being here today you
look like a prisoner
january 12th 2017.
there was an incident at the comedy
store involving a guest of mine which
caused pain and suffering
i'd like to take this opportunity to
apologize to everyone involved
or who may have been affected by said
incident
especially curtis
was punched in the face bitten
and called the n-word
i want to assure you all
i'll do everything in my power let's
make sure this never happens again
since i have you here
i'd like to promote my comedy show this
saturday night 8 30 p.m right here in my
apartment it's called ari's flaxseed
function we have a lot of great
comedians alex on saliaga theo van amir
kay dean delray joe bartnick i can't
wait to have you guys we're gonna have
people from craigslist meetup.com
yelp.com all happening here tomorrow
saturday night 8 30 p.m ari's flaxseed
function we'll see you there
i wish that was still a show i could
promote but
that would have been perfect for me but
yeah that was a 360 video so it's just
just rewind just rewind it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that's my favorite part
so that's yeah that's the full story i
think that's a great story that's a
great story is that girl hot or not like
she looked kind of cute there in the
pictures but the girl who got arrested
yeah yeah
she was
serviceable she was
she was beautiful in her
yeah she was she was not for everyone
let's say that right but for you both of
you
she was for us in that moment did
anybody ended up happening with me in
here did anybody really care
was anybody like don't really do that
yeah
yeah
but you you did you felt like it people
would yeah i was scared that people
would care and that i would have this
bad reputation and people be mad at me
but no one really cares because to me
that's just like a funny like i'm sure
every people are telling the story
that's funny some prostitutes here start
screaming for ari yeah that's great
that's a fun night of the comedy club in
my eyes it's like old school
80s to where i should just embrace it i
guess yeah it was not in that moment it
was not fun for me
yeah how long ago was that
uh i don't even know i should say
probably five five six years ago yeah
it was yesterday
it wasn't yesterday but what was oh no
two nights ago
jelly roll show oh yeah baby me and
little brows
thankfully jelly okay so jelly rolls
concert was sold out at the troubadour
do you know each other
i've heard of him he's like a
big guy big dude does music yeah and one
of his one of his biggest fans is the
rock the rock yeah
but uh so he he did a concert at the
troubadour i love your glasses georgie i
found them those look really cool
they fit you i know thank you
you look like a like a beatle
like george harrison something like that
yeah
like
so uh it was sold out i found out about
the concert because of austin
but you told me like what a few days
before or something like that yeah and
i'm like oh [ __ ] you're like should we
go i'm like i looked at the tickets and
like they're sold out i was like [ __ ]
what can we do
so then i didn't want to hit up jelly
because i don't like bothering him about
stuff but then austin's like nah man
just hit him up we can probably get
tickets well he's a big chin fan he's
that's what he says but i don't believe
it ever
well
but yeah i get a feeling you know
someone but still you like
don't want to yeah i don't want to
bother you i don't even like bothering
brendan weird tickets yeah yeah yeah i
get it yeah i i
i won't do because it's also like
especially if they're like jelly roll
they're sold out yeah if you're giving i
guess it's more a comedy club because
you can have standing room in a music
show but at a comedy club you're taking
seats that would be sold most of the
time and the funny time
funny thing is anytime someone hits me
up for comedy show tickets it's always
hey i tried buying them but they were
sold out can i get them anyway and
that's the only thing i can't give them
out yeah it's like hey if the comic club
could sell more tickets they would they
want to make more money max
but that's us but yeah so you but you
did and so i i reluctantly hit him up
and i'm like and he
was super cool he's like yeah i got you
bubba i got you and i go he's like who
how many people you want to bring tell
me how many people i'm like
uh just me and brows for now
so he he hooked me up with his uh his
term manager and they're like vip
get to the green room all that stuff and
we're gonna do an after party you gotta
come this and that so me and brows went
and it was freaking
it was honestly inspirational right so
inspirational it was cool because we
just got to play there me and jen played
yeah we actually played there
a few weeks before
ours was not as packed no
it was like a third of that the max is
what 500-ish i think it's a 500 cap room
yeah i felt like that was way more than
500 though yeah he packed it out you
guys played your music there we did yeah
me and chen got to headline that's uh
like a wild venue to i know yeah i
didn't realize
yeah i don't know i didn't realize how
legendary it was until ross told me
about it it was i always wanted to play
there and we ended up being able to book
it and like chainsmokers played the
night before us we played then the black
keys played oh my gosh so just to even
be like on the marquee between them was
cool yeah but uh yeah jelly packed it
out and it was fun to watch it was so
cool hanging out with them and so also
teddy swims we were talking about uh
talking about him off camera with you
he was there and brows introduced me to
him i didn't realize how
in the beginning i didn't know you know
who he was yeah but then i when i heard
him i'm like oh my god this guy is like
one of the best singers i've ever heard
he was there in the green room and did
they they didn't go on stage again no
he's because i haven't actually know
this boy i haven't heard teddy swim sing
but like jelly roll is like
he he's a superstar he had an
independent following that was huge
but now he's he signed with the label
for a [ __ ] ton of money he was on jimmy
kimmel last night yeah which is which is
like
he's blowing up
yeah it's different it's it's different
like i feel like comics get on
like late night shows and they don't
really get excited about i feel like for
these like musical acts and like abc i
don't know it's you have to be like
mainstream yeah
you have to have those networking
connections yeah uh it used to be that
way for comedy now
for comedy it's getting on joe rogan
yeah is the equipment
yeah
um but he
he's an incredible he was was he ever
like hip-hop i guess i haven't really
did he was like he has a whole rapping
right when he's younger a classic cipher
from when he first got out of prison i
would love to watch that i've never seen
him before oh cool guy stuff you know
yeah why are you asking so many
questions
you made it out and have anyone here
been a president i'm going to jail
detained
yeah see it's tough nope i haven't i
haven't i i ca i kid i also find it
interesting it was i was just like
trying to not be a narc
freak
but
we're not [ __ ] squares
[ __ ] happens you you spend you sitting
there for a nickel you get out
because he has on his bio usually
reformed drug dealers
okay there you go and he lives a
alternative lifestyle uh him him and his
his wife will will
go find a third they'll i believe they
have an only fans together he really he
has an only fan she does but i believe i
believe i don't know this for a fact uh
i like to say stuff when i don't know no
they they openly say they get girls they
bring girls in that that that i know is
public but i don't know if he's on the
only fans do they perform together i
don't think so adam 22 style i'll pay
for that
huh i'd pay for that
watch that guy do his
magic uh make another 360 video coming
up right now
but no but seeing him in the green room
when when me and uh austin went to the
green room he just had this freaking or
remember i was like dude he looks like a
[ __ ] superstar like an aura about him
god i want to find that video where he
sang when we were at theo's on
thanksgiving that seemed like something
we have it somewhere yeah i gotta find
it it seemed like something out of like
a camp movie
shin is playing the guitar
and jelly roll is like serenading us
on thanksgiving hannah baron is there
brendan it was people are eating off
like plastic plates behind yeah yeah
it was like family dinner find that
video
his um there was a fan last night
at his concert there was a fan that had
the
i hang drywall merch on he was like
crying in the audience and like so happy
to see him so like brought him up to the
green room and like gave him a full
experience stuff i have the video
there's yeah drop it yeah
it was cool
he's living the dream i want to find
this uh but he does like country now
like he sings basically like now he blew
up because of country son of a sinner
such a good song that's what that's what
he performed on kimmel i think and then
save me was like i think the song that
really blew up
sami has probably like
half a minute or 500 million at this
point
he just has everything in the world he
wants clearly he has enough to eat
he's got great music he's got a yeah
three thumbs yeah
what else what would make this guy
happier i want to i got to find this uh
thanksgiving jelly roll thing so what it
was just thanksgiving dinner at
brennan's house or what was this uh it
was king in the sting
thanksgiving episode uh yeah and we
were theo had just moved to nashville
pretty much and brendan was performing
in nashville gotcha jelly rolls in
nashville so we we booked them all and
we did it in theo's
or no the airbnb house uh that rental
yeah yes yes yeah and we had
thanksgiving there it was it was crazy
at the end of the episode we might have
it um
it was so
tight in there like there's low ceilings
and [ __ ] it's like a a-frame ceilings
and like there were six people in there
it worked out though this this gives me
life
specifically me too dude
if you hear this song when he's like
thanks on the morning
[Music]
but i keep having dead air when i try to
look for it you guys vamp i'm looking
for this
it's oh it's not in this episode it
might be at the very end but no she's
150.
no more sound until we find what we're
looking for out of the speaker if you if
you have your headphones on
we'll work on we'll work on it uh but
who's hannah baron hannah baron went
viral have you ever heard of uh noodling
noodling
noodling is catching catfish by sticking
your hand oh in the holes in the holes
yeah that's cool and she's the hottest
noodler in the world
she she's she's got she's caught massive
massive [ __ ] fish i'm surprised i
haven't heard of her that's awesome we
just talked about her one time we talked
about noodling on king and sting we
found a hilarious video with just some
the most redneck people in the world
noodling that news from the news site
yeah news uh episode yeah this is why
you're the man to put together this
trivia contest
everybody's coming together literally
the rain man a podcast i come in here
and i hear like half a theo quote and
i'm like
maybe they gotta fight george as the
final boss if they win i have a
my next project i want to start which i
have to not do for a while because i
take on too much work at one time but i
want to do an mma podcast that is a late
night show and my office is already set
up to
and i want george to be my producer for
it and not like
it's all mma related but monologue bit
guest guest
fight picks and desk couch
in studio that's the goal
surprise hasn't been done i'm sure
people have done it out there you know
but one hasn't caught on but not that i
know of two white guys and i'm talking
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah not too white guys
whenever two white guys talked about mma
on a podcast that never happened
make it happen guys
i'd say drop the rest of what you're
doing and do that focus on that yeah i
like it
all right sorry guys i gotta go
just please now takes george with him uh
the other everything feeds into each
other you gotta keep it going but uh
anna baron oh yeah hannah baron
we talked about the noodling
then people kept tagging
the world king in the sting on her
profile because she's like the noodling
queen
and we hit her up and she zoomed in and
then she became like a character
made a whole song about her oh yeah
things got out okay let's listen to the
song
that one we can get the copyright yeah
[ __ ] it
oh yes
that's it that's it this is it no well
yeah i want a video this i wanna hear
chin singing oh jelly roll sings jim
plays guitar yeah chins they're like
start that from the beginning
the whole thing
there's a song playing in the background
i think that's
cipher than girls that are instagram oh
damn
well that's the moment it happened but i
do not mind
oh they've got this
that's amazing
so what did they just put this over the
video
as like a hype video yeah we just yeah
this was peter who does a bunch of dope
over videos yes right dude it was such a
crazy
the group picture yeah that group
picture is an insane group of people
that's a
freaking dude that's it it makes no
sense and some people left is cat and
stevie there no
yeah cat and stevie were there
does riley still pop in on this past
weekend yeah he does yeah i'm a huge
riley mouth fan actually i kind of want
i really want to be hilarious who is it
you know what's funny the this the
singer that i do music with his name is
riley like that's his stage name and
always put him on the songs and like the
last album there was like comedians and
stuff on there and then there was riley
and people were getting so mad they go
where's riley mao
this is not him they were tagging riley
mal
like my friend was getting hate because
it wasn't riley mel
his
i've i've commented on a riley mao post
like every his handle looks like it says
like m4
u or something yeah yeah yeah what is it
trying to say it oh my friend yeah it's
riley m4a that's his instagram handle
and and that is that doesn't say that
looks like mao
oh [ __ ] i don't even realize that that's
why i read it as riley mao all the time
oh my god we cracked the case but riley
m4a is just video right is it m4a video
file like mp3 m4a i guess i think i
don't know
uh you would know that is m4a a video
type m4v
mp4 is mp4 that's right then i don't
know that just blew my mind though i
didn't realize it looked like mal that's
how i read it every time yeah call him
up right now i need to answer this
i do i need to get a phone set up i like
spontaneity and podcasts just calling
someone up getting an answer the fun
thing funny thing about riley mao is he
loves the attention from the podcast for
real so anytime he gets recognized or
like this us talking about him right now
he loves going i love that riley it's
like whenever he i just remember him
going hey can you tag me on instagram
yeah sure
he loves it uh what you
what you love about him is his biggest
detriment to being on the pot
[Laughter]
it's just so like uh endearing and sweet
tonight this kid is just like a normal
kid like
loves when he gets a message from
someone going i love you on theo's
pocket it's like his
makes him the happiest didn't he start
like in church like he was editing stuff
for his church and that's how he got
with theo he's religious i remember for
the the talent show that theo and
chelsea did or what was it called it was
some oh christmas livestream event
and i was helping out with it
we had a talent portion where we were
playing clips of
people that submitted to be on the
talent show and riley was sneaking in
people from his church to be in the
video
they all should have made it like they
didn't even submit to be on the talent
show but he just wanted them to be
stoked that he got their music yeah yeah
yeah on the submission so it's just
little snippets
and he'd be like you think anyone would
care if i snuck this one i'm like do it
dude
every three people was i uh so when theo
moved to nashville this was all actually
actually at the same time uh around like
thanksgiving
he moved to nashville and we had to find
a nashville producer and
we decided this time we didn't want to
try to get a fan just someone who wanted
to show up right uh someone who's who is
more there for their talents
passion yeah to look at it as a job
which then quickly didn't happen with
riley but
he's like i am a star would you even
know who theo was and then was like i
love this yeah in his defense he is a
star
but uh undeniable talent on mike but um
he
yeah so
i put out a message on this it's a
there's this course that i took called
full-time filmmaker it's an 800 course i
would recommend it to anyone not an ad
incredible
concise like learning video a to b you
want to be an a to z
uh
the guy
has a facebook group that you can only
get in if you purchase the 800 course
there's like 15 000 people in it the man
is he's rolling in it parker walmart
i think he's like
definitely heard of him yeah because you
do you you youtube how to do stuff and
he's got a lot of good tutorials i think
he's like mormon or something which it's
neither here nor nor he's religious as
well yeah which was really funny because
he's super religious a virgin saving
himself until marriage but says the n
word more than anyone
is that real should we cut that
where did jin go
what the [ __ ] you're talking about it
looks like either it was either a
business call or a woman call one he's
either in a fight with a girl yes
yes that's how you do it there you go
jordan i'm trying to fist bump your
brother
get out
chaos this is awesome
uh
we'll cut out some of the walls yeah but
it's so funny because i the whole time i
felt like chin was
about to come back so i almost felt like
yeah like i kind of felt like we were
like we're stalling kind of stalling a
little bit but no
no we're we're potted every time i come
here chin
has something
last time he's like i gotta go tell them
it was to get a tattoo
yeah that's been the story for three
weeks yeah this time it was like
mysteriously in the middle of recording
gotta go it's been a phone
but what is so important that i had to
take it right now it's got to be this is
cat's age i don't feel comfortable with
saying what i heard oh
[ __ ] the story
gets juicier oh medical is his neck
have you ever gotten an std no i'm smart
but you're smart even smart people can
you know they go away with medicine
medicine's the smartest thing ever you
know not all of them go away with
medicine that is true that's true
i know a guy who literally would get uh
chlamydia and then just not tell anyone
and go
we all know the person
um
i don't know that's what i don't know
you yeah
[Laughter]
he said get chlamydia and then just keep
[ __ ] yeah and would spread it to
everybody and not tell anyone on purpose
i already had
i no longer want to know this person oh
oh yeah
he knows he knows him
i'm pretty sure this is not good podcast
we can't we can't be talking so
i don't know how but i've never gotten
an std and i hate condoms
refuse to welcome yeah
that's jealous that's right yeah i mean
there's just
you never work on those i hate them i
won't worry if a girl says to me you
need to wear a condom i'll say let's
just cuddle
i'm good yeah
i just got a what
i'll try that i don't have one but she's
like you need it then i'm like okay
let's just kiss
let's hold hands watch a movie i i i had
the big c back in 14. what did you stand
for
[Music]
i didn't i didn't continue to have sex
with women and not tell them i got i got
antibiotics it goes away in three days
it's not a big deal i'm cutting that i
won't
we need something it's not a big deal it
really isn't i mean i've never had it
and i don't want it but it's not a big
deal have you browsed i've had the c one
time it said it's brother
earlier this year i had a really bad eye
infection which i thought was pink eye
it was so bad it wasn't getting better
someone's like you know you could get
chlamydia in your eye
and i hope it was so bad my eye hurt so
bad that i went to the doctor praying
that it was chlamydia so that i could
start fixing it but it wasn't chlamydia
conjunctivitis one of the two you know
yeah it was just a pink eye might have
been from taking naked photos with
chelsea lynn not sure but it was it
happened right around that time i get
eye infections a lot because i don't
take my contacts out i'm gonna burp
incredible podcast but uh
but no for real like i
all the time in high school i would get
it uh i started to like
change them more and it would happen
last but every once in a while
and it's the worst three days of my life
get laser or embrace your nerdy glasses
one of the two laser is the move because
i can't do glasses because i bend them
because i like to fall asleep to
watching stuff and i can't see without
watching stuff
a little insight into my life
i had something i was some transition i
wanted to do and i forgot it i need to
write more was it about training
no was it about chen it was about you
that's about ari ari is a jack of all
trades i was gonna do this earlier when
i was introducing him as comedy store
regular and we went an incredible
tangent
and that was that's why that's actually
good podcast when you can't talk about
what you thought you're going to because
it's such an easy conversation but what
i was going to say is a jack of all
trades he's also
a podcast mogul
he runs a studio called melrose podcast
and he's had literally the biggest
podcast in the world record and he's now
selling ads for king and the sting
but i feel like after dark let's be oh
yeah oh yeah sorry not not king and huge
thing important distinction another huge
podcast mogul company uh yeah i can sing
after dark
but uh
you've got quite quite the roster
i hope we're just not just a blip on the
radar and we're just in some packet and
don't get sold i want you out there not
only are you not a blip on the radar but
there's a i'm not going to say names but
there's a
big podcast that we sell ads for that
they're just a nightmare to work with so
we might not even do it anymore so
you're becoming bigger and bigger every
day on our radar but uh let's go
yeah no i started this podcast studio
during covid
honestly thought maybe i'll get my
podcast studio paid for from it like
that was my goal initially so maybe
it'll pay the re pay its own rent
and then now it i make more money from
this podcast studio than i do from stand
up than i do first beautiful that's my
podcast from anything else so it kind of
just turned into this organic
growing machine so
uh a couple things that you just led
into an incredible segue of something i
was remiss not to do at the top of the
show
he talked about organic
and
basically it was the whole philosophy of
detachment which led to your biggest
success in life and that is the vedantic
philosophy which is uh the philosophy
that james shara the ceo and proprietor
of magic mind has adopted and i have
magic mind in my backpack if you would
get some christian and a white cloth for
me wow
i take magic mind every single day yes
uh i realized multiple times a day i i
will admit i don't love the taste but it
doesn't matter because i love the
feeling it gives my body and you've also
i'm assuming then acclimated to the
taste where it it starts off harsh yeah
it gets easier but like i would never
sell it by the taste
i would sell it by how good for you it
is and how yeah how it creates focus and
just chewie got excited he saw packages
i actually have two
chapters of my life and it was before i
found magic mind and after i found magic
mine
that's how i when someone's like what
what are you talking about i'm like oh
that was pre-magic mine
and that this is not a unique story this
is most people who try magic mind it's
it's before it's bmm and a m
yep
and i don't think that's actually true
but when i take magic mine i do feel
like i could be a ufc fighter a
professional oh yeah that i could take
on anyone and could you do that
regularly without magic mind no without
it i'm a big giant [ __ ]
except he did fight someone at his uh
military academy
yeah we can reach read stories uh that
were on old cats after darks because
they're on patreon fourteen hundred
people watched i don't know it's i don't
remember any story i've told i don't
know what that says about me and my
brain wasn't you for magic mine you only
told me
someone was like
needling you at your uh
military school i got in two fights at
military school yeah so i went to i went
to a military high school i won one and
lost one and we're gonna hear
those stories again but only like me not
the audience
mind dot co slash dark promo code dark
25 percent off
uh honestly it's the once daily
anti-procrastination elixir it's it's
delicious i love it and even if it was
placebo which it's not having a routine
in your life is a really quick path to
success do the same thing every day
and
and you'll be fine it has neutral
nootropics in it so you know it's good
oh i like it too much i already drank it
oh nice nootropics are hot
did you well of course you seen it but
another podcast network there when you
posted the cool uh
colors of all the different magic minds
that was so cool that was a a legit fan
of my little podcast another podcast
show plug within a plug uh they they had
a bunch of empty
magic mine containers and they painted
the insides of them and they had like
the rainbow on their shelf in their art
studio with like a canvas it was like an
incredible picture can you go to
instagram.com another podcast network
but yeah not those stories
all right oh yeah so i went uh
how long have we been going
one hour 46 minutes oh damn time is just
flying by huh time flies by when you're
with the boys yeah do you feel like it's
flying by no it is yeah i i because i
felt like we covered a lot for you six
minutes and i actually think this is
going well there's lulls but uh i did
think it was longer than that well i i
am i like autistics i always like you
are on the spectrum i it's so [ __ ] in
vogue to be on the spectrum
you have you been on the spectrum for
years you've thought or just yeah i
never knew it and still to this day no
doctor has diagnosed me with it but i
claim it now hard okay see that's what
i'm saying it's it's kind of hot
everybody's kind of claiming it but also
the the logical thing is the definition
of on the spectrum is that we are all on
the spectrum it's from
zero to one and everything in between so
but i also think i i don't know [ __ ]
oh yeah you're autistic for sure oh yeah
you're more autistic than me oh yeah
hell yeah
[Laughter]
oh come on right there i'm full blown
tism
basically if you listen to podcasts more
than four hours a day
if you listen to a podcast and then
think you can host a podcast
you might be autistic right it's our
jeff foxworthy
you might be a redneck
uh is that the magic mine rainbow mural
yeah the first post the most recent
great clip right there
well they have other flavors talking
about uh
autism
yeah is that just for looks are those
other secret flavors of magic mine no
that's just for looks this was this was
a fan of my podcast
uh not this one
who took
yeah another
uh
and yeah i think that's beautiful
that's awesome but kind of
crazy that they that guy better get have
gotten sent a free case of magic mine
from that post james uh
they will
and also uh
wow
misogyny that was a woman
oh
damn insane michael i didn't i assumed
that was a man it's artsy it's beautiful
it could be a woman why do you assume
because it's artsy that's beautiful come
on just damn it
we bring you on the podcast we're trying
to be woke you know what i'll admit it
i have a little sexism in my body and i
think that's because me and my mom don't
get along so it's not my fault
okay i'm only kidding i believe in
gender roles uh but yeah so you got in
two fights in military
that's why it's texas from going to an
all-boys military school
uh yeah i saw was a naughty boy got sent
to military school in roswell roswell
new mexico
what's happening
okay
and they at military school
they put you in rooms
they picked your roommates based on your
weight
and that would be perfect that was
because some people fight in fights oh
yeah that if they
put you in yeah they weight class you
buy your roommate so if you weighed 100
pounds they try and get you a 100 pound
roommate but what is fair what if it was
a 100 pound wrestler versus someone who
is just regularly say that actually
uh me and my roommate were the two
smallest kids in the school
i weighed i think
about 100 pounds is 9th grade i was 13
or 13 years old and he weighed like 90
pounds there's this little uh asian guy
a chinese guy from diamond bar
california not too far from here
and he sounds like a strip club
yeah they have them he is um he joined
the wrestling team
at this military school
and i don't know if you guys have ever
done
combat sports it sounds like you have
unsusceptible
no no combat support well you're all
fake fight you're into ufc yeah you
boxing
hola
put a pin in what i just asked you i
just had an epiphany
all right
no no i want over here sorry
okay so
i have this 90 pound wrestling roommate
now i feel like i'm rushing you through
the story so
should i say my thing okay okay
how old are you i'm 23. 23. all right oh
you're really looking forward to that
23. okay let's get through it pretend i
didn't even say anything about 15. so
i was telling them a story about how i
have a 90 pound asian chinese roommate
in military school asian chinese he's
asian and chinese okay i mean that i
hope so i'm willing to stand by that
chin is everything okay yeah
everything's good the doctor what's it
your neck
uh no no okay yeah
okay
that's all i'm saying um he learned
about his neck i feel like maybe we
should bail from the story no
keep going
so he took wrestling
and i don't know if you guys ever taken
combat sports when you do it gives you a
lot of confidence in yourself that's
what i think any work if you start
working out a lot you feel better about
yourself so he had a lot of confidence
we already didn't like each other so now
he got into this mentality of i'm gonna
kick your ass i'm a wrestler now and
i'll beat you up can i can i get i think
all people should put their children in
martial arts because it does give you
self self confidence and just like a
feeling of security but this is a story
of where that confidence
goes wrong
if you're like an angry kid who gets
kicked out of a high school and sent to
a military academy i can see how you use
those powers for evil
okay so so he starts trying to wrestle
me basically he like literally i i
remember that he opens up a fight like
this is a real fight not a wrestling
match
in our room
by grab like hugging me and trying to
lift me up from the backer front from
the
his front and my front body left front
yeah body language
so he tried to body lock me locked yeah
and uh but not unsuccessfully he was way
smaller way shorter than me wait time
than me all i did was literally punch
him in the face
and he was trying and he was wearing
glasses i hurt my hand and his face
uh
and that was pretty much the end i think
i kicked him one i punched him he fell
to the ground and then i kicked him and
that was like the end of the fight and
he started crying
so and that was my first fight of my
life how was my first actual fight hell
yeah so i wanted one
but he's your buddy though right no yeah
he's my roommate and we hated each other
that's a great oh okay but you're
roommates though yeah yeah
then the second fight was also because
of him
in the next door neighbor he went over
to the next door neighbor
and said hey ari said he [ __ ] your
girlfriend
that guy i never met this guy's
girlfriend
my roommate went over our neighbor and
said ari has been saying he [ __ ] your
girlfriend oh my god i never said that i
never met this guy's girlfriend and that
guy knew that he comes over to my room
and he goes hey ari heard you [ __ ] my
girlfriend
and then my dumbass goes
you bet i did i [ __ ] her dude
and then he just starts wailing on me
and beating the [ __ ] out of me and that
was my second and finally he wouldn't
even ask his girlfriend first like hey
did something happen he knew i didn't
[ __ ] his girlfriend he just wanted just
a respect thing i disrespected him
you didn't disrespect him you didn't say
anything
but well then i did oh i didn't
initially but then he said yeah i did
instead of me going i didn't [ __ ] your
girlfriend i didn't say that i go down
yeah i [ __ ] you
because ari's a comedian at heart that's
the only response yeah that's the
comedian got his ass beat
and then fight number two that was it
that was oh yeah oh yeah yeah
my epiphany
george is 23.
i really want to live vicariously
through george
i i've always wanted to do a
professional mma fight i want to get
and i know small promotions that we
could get you on
we should get you in a professional mma
fight but why though
does he want to i think i i that's the
big question
i'm going to answer for him i think he
does
fine like you know jiu jitsu competition
would be great but not mma so with uh
one of the ceos of bellator uh rich
vaughn richard chow one which child's a
yeah
you're already
he has a program that he takes oh yeah
beginners and puts them through so it
starts january or no uh july 16th to
december 3rd and it's one hour a day and
you train and at the end of it you can
have a sleeper fight with somebody at
your exact same level so i start that in
like two weeks you're doing it that's
amazing so i'm already on it
look at me man
you actually signed up for it yeah
brendan got it set up for me it's like
from wimp to warrior or something like
that right yeah yeah i think they
changed the name around a little bit
just for me
i think they made it something a little
left of me
like cool guy and a fighter
geez do you really want to do this
georgie yeah it's at a legacy bjj and
burbank then i'm going to be an hour a
day having fun holy crap nice to meet
you had so much worry in his voice when
he said i do want to do this
yeah it's like you fold everything jiu
jitsu wrestling boxing
literally mma you were gonna bring it
can crowd go
um i'm sure
i'm sure like uh
at the like the fight part yeah you
should talk to him about streaming like
they do stream it we will get people
behind this yeah let me stream it you're
going to put up numbies george
and if you want to see updates on it go
to my vlog go george go on youtube
because i'm going to be recording it i'm
going to do a fight companion for it
it'll be getting
him
i'll bet on you baby i believe in you
thank you thank you or we could just
i'll take the other guy i'll get some
action
i will i would never
i want to do it but i want to fight a
woman at the end
yeah that could be that i said i have a
chance that's the whole the same level
that's the whole idea of the competition
[Laughter]
put that on the card right before
george's fight oh yeah the undercover
i'll be the undercard yeah george you've
done an admirable job but do you want to
do your news uh yeah of course chin do
you want to trade me shots
he is news he broke brings news
news with george hi guys
ari you have any guests you want to
pitch us
yes
like on your network oh oh guests to
potentially come on this podcast yeah
the comedians you had i heard you had
matt lockwood and morgan how was their
experience
they
had fun i think yeah they said they
liked it i think they did i think they
did too they're hilarious they're great
they're effortlessly just they're
they're good hangs yeah they're good
hands
uh
you could probably honestly book bigger
guests than i could because your this
podcast network could i know just saying
hey for this if you if you reached out
to someone and said hey would you want
to come on the thick boys channel on
cats after dark i bet you could get some
bigger
pretty big names i think we can
too uh
schedule some crazy and people have been
quitting right and left so
uh but they're done taking time off
they'll be back yeah i also i want him
to have some like tie-in kind of i guess
but
i don't know like we're
people who i had great chemistry with on
my podcast that i think would be good on
here maybe like a blair sake
or a jessame peluso
or i i i like both thinking about having
chappelle ac on the podcast uh
his name has been kicked around
but that would be great too cat would be
awesome yeah yeah should i get both of
them on at the same time that'd be dope
all right uh i'm gonna text george to
try to take him out he's being a piece
because i've been holding him the whole
time but he's also kind of struggling to
get out all right so my first animal
video that i got for today this one's
very chin centric i want chin's opinion
on us because this is some crazy stuff
is this fish swimming under ice look at
it what is it
no way he got his head cut off what the
what
and he's just chilling god what kind of
what is that i think that's an armored
something fish
probably from florida
but what happened to him
something something must have ate his
head but then it's all nerves you know
nerves are kicking in so is it dead or
alive right now it has to be dead
maybe it only ate the mouth
part of the face and it's brain
have you ever seen someone like failed
suicide shotgun to the face jaws off but
they're yeah they're still kicking isn't
that the eyes right there
i was gonna go
that's a good point though i don't know
i usually i can see gills if i see gills
it looks like the gills are cut off too
though i can't tell
damn this is your specialty i know if
there's gills
but you know like when you you can even
have uh
tunas when you
like literally take their head off and
you start filleting them uh-huh they'll
start bouncing around the table they
float around for a minute right do you
think the cold water kept the nerves
going a little bit i've seen like
catfish or other fish move for hours
after you kill them even like uh
ocean heels like yeah fish eels there
was a viral tick tock of this fish they
put it on the pan and they put oil on
hot oil on it and it's the nerve
starting flopping around in the pan i
hate seeing that dude it's so disturbing
that's wild
and then i got one more if it pulls up
now this
is crazy they're baby owls
i don't know how they got here they're
probably born there is that a house yeah
but look
i can't see look at these baby elf oh my
god there's no way that's this is why
people thought aliens what was that
this is not real those are baby owls
yeah that's what they look like without
but we're standing up like that that's
how bad that's how they're intrigued
oh my god imagine seeing that a hundred
hours ago i would shriek like a woman
like if i saw that 100 years ago i'd go
to the town center i'd go to town center
and be like i saw these two aliens in my
house
they're tiny aliens hold on go back to
the still shot of them is that how they
stand up regularly without like when
they have their wings and stuff they do
do that they you know like is that what
else looked like with
i understand if it was on a branch i'd
get it even the way it blinked was very
frightening yeah one blink but that was
scary
they do look like yeah
i don't i don't want to like
step on your toes but podcast rain man
we covered this on this past weekend
2018. theo's been talking about what an
owl looks like without his feathers
freezing
um
one of you fans think you can beat me
that actually is the game though
ultimately the winner
the they face george
final boss yeah but it's gonna be so
tough because he's gonna be making the
game in the lead up to it
so it's like just cramming you might
have to make the final one for oh yeah
he definitely can't make the last game
but like still just making the game
we'll be researching this now that i
know that i'm not making the last game
uh
i mean that was a good clip though
because i remember theo saying that
about eating owl meat and like how
there's none
um that doesn't look like much media he
did he did it on jre first and then i
think he expanded and i can't remember
the guest
on this past weekend but he
he talked about oh that's creepy as [ __ ]
though that is so creepy especially
there's two of them right next to each
other inside a freaking attic or
whatever that is i feel like it was
super unlikable what i just did to
george
you need to feed owls every few hours so
it's really hard to keep a pet owl
because you can't even leave for a day
if you leave for a day that owl will die
[ __ ]
they're needy [ __ ]
they can also move their head 270
degrees everybody knows that that's like
the [ __ ] hack owl that's also yours
was way better i don't know why i tried
it i said it and as i was saying it i
was losing confidence in my face oh no
it was good i made this up but i
remember doing the research it's because
i think i was like looking i'm trying to
get george to take chewy out just so we
can have 15 more minutes where he chills
out are you talking about me george no
no no it's dual dual switch we talked
about it okay okay
i just got real aggressive with you what
is that what is you
what is the distinction between names uh
for you guys cause i call you both a lot
of people call him crojo or
paul george i'm big george because i
used to be big
um rick george is cool yeah thank you
when i was big i was tiny or little
george so georgie's my favorite
it's like the end of the podcast too but
i just need we need 10 minutes where
he's not in
i'm like a bad single dad
all right i wanted to talk to you about
um
producer stuff
like the days i have off
i'd love to produce podcasts and i think
you might have connections or something
like that do you actually yeah i have a
feeling the producer
jobs that i could offer you
you're above like we pay 50 bucks an
hour
okay i won't do that but
i haven't felt something more than that
you're too uh you're you're past that
you're past what i have to offer you
we'll see we'll talk about that
50 bucks an hour
it's funny that 50 an hour which
understandably so that's some people are
like never mind i don't want to do that
but to some people like 50 bucks an hour
yeah i've been i'll freaking quit my
whole life
for fifty dollars an hour i mean i won't
do that
what and the shitty part here's the
other thing that makes it less cool to
someone who's like 50 bucks an hour
you're turning that down it's not an
eight-hour shift of 50 no it's not an
hour it's like a couple hours at 50
so you're really driving across town for
100 bucks and then at that point
yeah worth it i don't know when i did
freelance podcasting stuff i charge a
minimum 500 bucks an hour
damn and that's just audio not even
video money bag i got to change they
changed my whole business model
no but that's all that's how you got
people in the door and now you've you've
parlayed it into ads
but like also
that's a ton of leg work if you're like
i'm just i do what i do when i need my
rate then you get i don't know there's
different business models and you're
like a famous podcast producer am i
though yeah you're a premium because
people who hire you are like bringing
you're on my favorite podcast and you
produce that one so i want it just like
that whereas i feel like we're all like
about to encourage chin to leave this
job
i feel like you're getting
i need to leave this time
i'm making more money
what do you want to make more money for
if you had if i handed you 5 million
bucks right now which i don't have to be
clear yeah uh what would you
what are you saving for i would want to
buy my parents a house first then i'll
take care of myself after that you want
to buy your parents for the house before
you buy yourself yeah that's my number
one goal yeah well wow so i'm not making
enough money for that yet so so i'm
trying to like make money on the side
i love that thank you it's a beautiful
story i love uh
in
where do your parents live
in santa ana orange county oh still
expensive okay it's not a great like
santa is like a
depends on where you're at in santa ana
it's kind of ghetto where they're at but
where they're at is like
it's ghetto around them but where
they're at in their block is not that
bad but it's still socal so buying them
a house it's not like they live in
mesquite texas where you're like here's
a hundred thousand dollars get yourself
a house yeah
yeah american gangster that's what i was
looking for he goes mama that's your
house oh he buys her a house
yeah mama that's your house i would love
seeing that
they'd be if you bought your parents
house what would they react would they
cry or would they would they just say
thank you son
no no so my dad's like he's
he's so like military
he was from the rock marines in korea he
served like three years or something
like that he's just super just quiet
military guy no reaction my mom's very
like loving and
you know i'm a mama's boy so she would
be like crying my dad probably like have
like a little tear just kind of slow
down
like the native dick and littering tears
yeah
do they own a house or they they renters
it's not even paid off yet so yeah they
have a house so they do have a house so
maybe i want to buy them like a really
nice house you want to buy them yeah
yeah a nice house that's paid off they
don't worry about anything just live off
their retirement and the money that my
brother and i give them
damn you're a good good guy
do you have i told you that i would
never want to buy them
[Laughter]
they're lucky i get them anything for
their birthdays no i don't know but no
that's very nice are they fairly
stress-free your parents
they don't need me to buy that that's
that may be the difference
that's part of the difference no one
likes to see the struggle
what would you do if you're rich nick uh
that would be my also my first goal i
would help my grandma get her sister who
has alzheimer's whose husband's about to
die in denver and is like a ward of the
state back to wisconsin because i feel
like you tried so hard to one-up chin
things are
yeah
alzheimer's all right that's hot right
now
what are your actual parents they're
schizophrenic and not in the picture
it's cool it's cool man
i think we i think it's been discussed
briefly on uh yeah sometimes we get like
on king and the sting there's just like
these insights into people's life which
i love that james or share episode of
this when they were like
he asked you and kat how you doing
podcasting they got way deep it was
super super deep below the line
is that the name of the podcast below
the line or something else let's get one
more news story it's called below the
line or another below deck podcast
um
so
let me
freakin send this over
this is something that you guys wrote
down
for me in the
google drive but travis
bart travis what the heck drummer blink
182. yes he's a big fan
of tattoos nobody likes you
and i also have been watching every
episode of the kardashians hulu show is
it good i had never dated kardashian
i have like drama how did it sound what
did it sound like i said
i didn't say date no you you said you
were just watching the kardashians yeah
yeah
huh
oh okay were you because it wasn't the
equal to what he does
i don't know what's happening don't
worry about what's happening oh i
thought you said i thought you heard
that i said i dated our kardashian
i have only watched every episode of the
kardashians and hulu i have never
watched me that you've never dated a
criminal i don't think anyone was
confused most people think of nick
brodie and they think he [ __ ]
celebrities
that's i know
that's that's why i wanted to clear it
up i don't like
murky waters
i know i know it seems stilted and we
like hung on that for a while but i just
didn't want anybody to continue to think
that i have not [ __ ] a car
thank god what yeah what happened to him
um i think it said
let me pull it up on mine brandon
actually mentioned something like he
said what happened to him but i forgot
what it was
like something [ __ ] i forgot
he tweeted like god saved me or you
didn't love me
pancreatitis yeah pancreatitis yeah
something like that i don't know
george george nailed it
you gave it i butchered it you gave it
extra tie i think in there someplace
yeah but it's all good pancreatitis
pancreas which one is it it's
pancreatitis oh guys doctors believe it
was triggered by a recent colonoscopy
um why would he get a colonoscopy talk
about your all-time backfires
i like that
it's the opposite of what it's for it's
supposed to prevent it's a preventative
measure is it called colonoscopy when
they put water in your ass and no no no
it's a camera that that's a uh um
oh i'm mixing it up i should know that
uh not an ad my sister runs move
colonics in minneapolis somebody not a
good job
good gig she's killing it
she has like she has like nurses and she
goes to hawaii six months out a year
it's just killing it she's doing a good
service
oh i never feel fully cleared out so
that's cats after dark are you here
all right where can we find you what do
you have to plug uh not much just me my
podcast ari manis that's all i got today
but thanks for having me and god bless
each and every one of you god bless you
god bless you too
i think this is going to be a fire
episode unlicensed therapy that's marie
unlicensed therapy uh george you can
catch me on go george go on youtube and
uh on instagram at georgeharris48
bring it up let's just go around the
room
anybody can go
oh uh you can just find me on instagram
at see payload six and
that's about it
six
and then browse yeah on instagram at low
brows youtube low brows um what i got
going on got a new song coming out uh
called arizona
pre-save will be available by the time
this episode drops yeah so pre-order
that pre-save it and the songs featuring
austin awake and you're not quitting but
you are gone for two weeks i'll be gone
for two weeks uh where are you going and
what are you doing i'm going to arizona
to film the video
what's the video for oh it's
i kid i kid
we nailed it we did that often we did it
it was it hit it was good if i ruined it
though but it seemed natural as [ __ ]
um yeah i'll be gone for a couple weeks
i'll be back and uh going on a little
vacay with the fam i can't have aria on
camera right now because he seems
checked out
can we just
click me i could i thought i did my plug
i thought it was over here
same camera
same camera same camera
just kidding i'll go one it's 4k uh
and another podcast show
and what i got going on is a ton of
stuff
i'm just kidding nope so but me and
brows we're going we're going on a tour
this year it's insane so the first ones
that is where is it at
yeah so you may do the dates yeah okay
so august 12th we're in austin texas
august 28th we're in ohio and then we
have some those are the two confirmed we
have one uh we're doing an edm festival
which is crazy which is nuts like
opening for hippie sabotage and um
floster domes
uh so yeah we're gonna be doing some
shows and we'll post the tour dates link
in our bio all that
yeah pretty cool hopefully hopefully you
guys can all come out to at least one of
the shows if it's in l.a yeah what's not
in l.a man it's in texas and [ __ ]
ohio you didn't even come to the one in
l.a
yeah
[Laughter]
legendary troubadour you couldn't make
it but whatever next time next time next
time you guys headline there hat and
stevie came too yeah dude dude so many
people came mm-hmm you guys georgie came
nick came
no yeah with the porn yeah he came on
his own a lot of that will be cut out
that's fine that's fine sorry jules love
you
solid show solid show guys after dark
out
[Music]
[Music]
you